so for the second case he has stayed in  a hotel all night while here symptoms so  we are now sending stuff to do the site  with sit together with the star front of  our Mental Hygiene department to try to  make sure that the room has been  disinfected well and also the common  area has been disinfected well and also  we'll do further contact tracing there  so so far we have identified the three  close contest for these two cases all  this contact tracing has been and it's  being carried out on going so we are  asking all those people with who had  travelled in the same must be trained to  come forward  and also those passengers who had landed  some journey for the first case for the  second case to come forward so the  concentration is being carried out